als luke herzlich willkommen ich heute
meine damen und herren zu einer neuen
ein euro jobs im jahr haben julia und
ich schon mal einen euro challenge hier
auf meinem kanal hochgeladen
da war julia einfach im teddy also einem
laden in dem fast jedes produkt einen
euro kostet ich und ich habe mich
komplettes scheiße gekauft jude war auf
jeden fall dieses mal ein euro laden und
hat eine komplette tüte voll mit sachen
gekauft und das hat sie jetzt wieder
gemacht und ich weiß nicht was es ist
und werde da jetzt einfach mal rein
greift bevor ich da allerdings das erste
mal eingreifen möchte ich euch noch ganz
gut sagen dass ich gleich live bin oft
widge.de v schrecklich laser do.com 20
uhr mache ich dort meinen ersten
richtigen livestream mit ford werken ich
werde auf youtube videos reagieren ich
werde mich mit euch unterhalten ich
werde fragen beantworten über themen
reden die ezb wird also auf jeden fall
sehr sehr cool aber ich greife jetzt mal
das erst mal in die box rein das erste
produkt das sich hieraus hole ich habe
ein bisschen tiefer direkt rein ist dass
hier jeder nutzen also dass hier sind
dass ich dachte erst das wäre eine
wassermelone die man so auf klappt und
dann hat man so eine wassermelone aber
gut okay dass auf jeden fall das erste
produkt das zweite wurde dass sich
herausnehmen ist dafür
dein ernst ein vierteiliges
prinzessinnen haar set soll jetzt das
kann ja auch aussetzen april versucht
gerade hinter der kamera dieses
prinzessin in sap zusammen zu bauen wir
werden allerdings gar keine zeit
verliert ich werde direkt wieder in die
tüte reingreifen das nächste produkt was
nämlich haben es die gäste nur solche
sachen die ich wegen die anziehen soll
der mitmenschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abgeschlossen das nächste produkt habe
ich auch gerade schon aus als sie mich
rausgenommen haben und zwar ist das hier
das sind romehome sind noch mal kommen
solche ziehen engels cheerleader melonen
flügel schule praktiziert der kamera
wieder die promis aus sie hat allerdings
diese prinzessinnen krone fertig
ausgepackt
einen spalt die ich habe keine ahnung
was ist das für ein video sie bin jetzt
hier eine prinzessin und haben somit war
die zweite klick unter dem video auf
abonnieren oder ihre ärmel rutschen
runter beim händewaschen xd just im
ernst eigentlich wollte ich gerade schon
auch wenn man bei juli meinte dann ich
soll noch warten mit dem foto weil sie
eventuell noch mehr das video hat das
heißt gerade jetzt direkt mal wieder ein
und das nächste was ich mir heraushole
von einer rutschpartie socken
[Musik]
was also dass hier sind die socken aber
es hat sogar zwei paar weil im angebot
waren einmal hier mit hello kittys doch
dieses ding drin jule und das hier ist
das andere paar socken
das ist auch hello kitty also ist beides
hello kitty dies kommt noch dieses
plastikding als maul
wie finde ich meinen neuen abstoßen das
praktisch ist dass ich jetzt hier viel
zu oft man einen fuß habe also im winter
echten mega dann habe ich meine das ist
megageil
allerdings machen wir direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten produkt das unibody gekauft
hat und zwar greift nicht ganz tief
wieder hier in die tasche rein und wir
haben das hier in dino das ist ein dino
greifer ja also das hier sei die not
greift weil ich habe keine ahnung was
das sein sondern muss kommt ohnehin das
nächste teil greift mir dann
selbstverständlich auch mit diesem
greifbar und zwar die ganze tüte das mit
dem einfach funktioniert nicht so
richtig das heißt ich hätte einfach
wieder normalen die tüte rein und das
nächste produkt das wir haben das
ziemlich schwer als es nämlich da eine
zwei euro garten platten sind
der fuß liegt jetzt auf jeden fall oben
auf meiner terrasse hat dort einen mega
schönen platz gefunden wie ich finde ja
was machen wir
ich glaube jeder kritisierte rein und
das nächste produkt was wir haben jetzt
ziemlich klein und leicht ist nämlich
dass hier ein glas mit runden pr-team
rund oder team katze schreibt mal und in
die kommentare wirklich medizin ist ja
schon übel streitthema was mache ich
hier aber gut wir greifen wir wieder
unten in die tätigte der ist mir noch
einiges drin und zwar als nächstes das
hier das wird nie verkleidet klebe ich
mir jetzt nicht auch noch in die waren
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten produkt und zwar es ist da dass
das ist eine bierglas kerze das riecht
nicht mal nach bier also dankeschön auf
jeden fall auch für diese kerze
jugendlich greift direkt mal wieder hier
unten recht ordentlich viele sachen
gekauft einmal janosch heißt er als
summa summarum look zeigen
das ist auf jeden fall eine janosch
trinkflasche für kinder
wenn ich auf jeden fall nächstes mal
nicht mit ins team nehmen allerdings
wieder und in die tüte rein da ist noch
so viel kram
wir müssen uns erst einmal ein bisschen
beeilen solar backen meerjungfrau das
heißt sie kann ich da hinstellen wo die
sonne hin scheint dann wackelt auch
dankeschön auf jeden fall auch für die
solar- und wackel meerjungfrau wurde es
echt mega lieb von dir und ich greife
wieder ganz tief unten in die tüte rein
wir haben die macher direkt weiter mit
dem nächsten produkt hier auch satirisch
wird uns was ist bitte markiert nicht
auf allen lebensmitteln ich glaube die
tüte ist aber mittlerweile schon fast
leer und zwar haben wir hier vorne noch
eine sache dass es auch eine brille
vielleicht wieder dort darüber jedoch
ein team so wenn ich geburtstag habe ich
dann die brille auf und dann wenn ich
tot bin
die auf da kann ich schnell zwischen
aber gut ich habe optionen noch was drin
ist irgendwo natürlich haben wir
tatsächlich noch ein produkt und weise
einfach ein achter pack batterien danke
dafür dass du mich heute mal wieder so
schön eingekleidet hat ich stellte mich
das heutige video soll dieser auch
beendet meine lieben freunde wenn euch
dieser zweite teil mehr oder weniger von
einem euro challenge gefallen hat wie
gesagt haben juli nicht das ja schon von
einem jahr gemacht aber wenn euch das
heute wieder gefallen an das unbedingt
einen daumen hoch unter diesem video
dhabi zu beginnen bereits gesagt wenn
ich heute abend ab 20 uhr live auf
news.at schrägstrich laser luca ich
werde mich mit euch unterhalten
wir werden
fragen beantwortet werden uns zusammen
videos anschauen ich werde zocken zu
bestimmten themen meine meinung sagen
die zentren bieten ganz ganz cooler
leichtem ich hoffe ihr seid damit dabei
abonniert main kanal falls sie keine
videos mehr verpassen wollte noch keine
zeile luxury seit und jetzt kommt
endlich das auto nicht in ruhe
[Musik]